lo que haremos en este vídeo es estudiar
una demostración del teorema de
pitágoras el cual bueno la prueba fue
descubierta por este galán james
garfield en 1876 y lo genial de esto es
que james no era un matemático
profesionalmente hablando no tal vez tú
lo conozcas a james como como el
veinteavo presidente de eeuu y fue
electo presidente en el año de 1880 y
fue presidente en el 81
ahora bien james hizo esta prueba
mientras era miembro de la llamada casa
de representantes de eeuu y lo
espectacular de esto es que bueno ahora
ya con james y abraham y con abraham
lincoln ahora ya no fue el único
presidente de eeuu a quien le interesó
la geometría porque ahora bueno tiene
como acompañante a james garfield y lo
que james se da cuenta es que construyes
un triángulo rectángulo y es lo que
estoy haciendo aquí tenemos la longitud
y la longitud y tenemos la hipotenusa de
este triángulo rectángulo
longitud ce en la hipotenusa y bueno ahí
ya tenemos el triángulo rectángulo que
estábamos que construimos ahora lo que
lo genial lo que hace james garfield
este apuesto caballero james garfield es
es voltear este triángulo lo voltea y lo
rota ajá y así construye un nuevo
triángulo que es congruente al primer
triángulo es lo que estoy haciendo aquí
o intentando hacer entonces ahí tenemos
la longitud del triángulo y bueno es co
lineal a la longitud ambas sobre la
misma línea y no se solapa entonces ahí
está la longitud de la longitud
y el triángulo rectángulo bueno el
ángulo recto más bien y aquí está la
hipotenusa entonces ya construye el otro
triángulo ahora lo primero en lo que
queremos pensar es cuánto mide el ángulo
que se forma entre las dos hipotenusa es
este ángulo misterioso tal vez te pueda
parecer un ángulo familiar pero bueno
vamos a ver si mide si mide eso que
estamos pensando si observamos el
triángulo original y llamamos a este
ángulo a este ángulo theta cuánto mide
este ángulo cuánto mide ok el ángulo el
ángulo entre lado ai el lado c cuánto
mide ese ángulo sabemos que la suma de
los ángulos internos de un triángulo es
igual a 180 entonces eso nos dice que
estos dos ángulos deben medir 90 porque
90 más el ángulo recto sería igual a 180
en total así que este ángulo mide 90
menos theta ahora este triángulo es
congruente al otro triángulo así que sus
ángulos corresponden entonces este
ángulo mide teta y este ángulo 90 menos
y ya con esto regresamos a la pregunta a
la pregunta del millón cuánto mide el
ángulo misterioso porque parece que
estos tres colectivamente esos tres
ángulos miden 180 grados entonces éste
está más 90 menos theta más el ángulo
misterioso es igual a 180 los ángulos
theta se cancelan y nos queda que 90 más
el ángulo misterioso es igual a 180
restamos 90 de ambos lados de la
ecuación y nos queda que el ángulo
misterioso es igual a 90 grados así que
el recto perfecto ahí ya ya terminamos
por esa parte y entonces bueno en
definitiva este ángulo este ángulo como
lo pensábamos al inicio es un ángulo
recto borró esto y aquí le pongo el
cuadrito es un ángulo recto este ángulo
que se forma entre las dos hipotenusa
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es construir
un trapecio este lado este lado
es paralelo al lado b así fue construido
y aquí tenemos un lado del trapecio
ahora vamos a conectar los otros dos
lados que quedan estos
para que se forme el trapecio deseado y
pensemos en el área del trapecio una
manera de pensar en el área del trapecio
es simplemente pensar en esto y bueno a
averiguar el área verdad o pensar en la
suma de las áreas de los triángulos que
se forman en esta figura así que
pensemos en esto como un trapecio que
sabemos sobre el área de un trapecio el
área de un trapecio será será su altura
la cual es a más b
esta es su altura
la altura del trapecio entonces a mars
ver multiplicado por el promedio el
promedio de estos dos lados entonces
tenemos x
un medio por un medio de a ve entonces a
más ve por un medio y x a más ve
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
tomar la altura multiplicarla por el
promedio de la base y lo que es el techo
bueno el lado a el de arriba eso nos da
el área del trapecio ahora como podemos
averiguar el área con sus componentes
siempre y cuando hagamos lo correcto no
no importa no no importa cómo lo hagamos
vamos a llegar al mismo resultado
entonces cómo podemos llegar al área del
trapecio podemos decir que el área de
que podemos tomar el área de sus
triángulos entonces el área de cada uno
de sus triángulos por ejemplo este sería
un medio a por b baja un medio por la
base y la altura pero hay dos de ellos
entonces multiplicamos por un 2 cierto
tenemos dos triángulos entonces
multiplicamos por 2 2 por un medio por a
por b eso considera a este triángulo
a este triángulo y a este triángulo
ahora cuál es el área del triángulo
grande cuál es cuál es ok lo voy a
colorear el color en color verde y cuál
es el área de este triángulo bastante
directo sale porque porque es
simplemente un medio se al cuadrado
cierto un medio por la altura que se y
la base que ese entonces un medio sea al
cuadrado ahora hay que ya tenemos todo
esto ya tenemos estamos hasta ahorita
creo que muy bien ahora vamos a
simplificar tenemos un medio y tenemos a
más de dos veces entonces un medio por a
más p
al cuadrado y esto es igual esto es
igual a 2 por un medio eso se cancela
eso es simplemente 1 y nos queda nos
queda a por ver a por esto estoy
intentando mantener los colores más un
medio sea al cuadrado pero creo que no
está funcionando porque me estoy
tardando mucho ya tenemos todo esto
entonces vamos a desarrollar aquí voy a
multiplicar por 12 para para que se
cancele ese un medio entonces
simplemente nos va a quedar de este lado
del lado izquierdo a más ven a más ve al
cuadrado es igual es igual aquí tenemos
al 2 que está multiplicando entonces 2 x
a por b
por de más aquí se cancela con en un
medio y nos queda simplemente más sea al
cuadrado entonces ya tenemos todo esto
voy a desarrollar el lado el lado
izquierdo y si hago eso nos queda al
cuadrado más
+ 2
por ver
más ve al cuadrado y del lado derecho
nos queda igual entonces eso es igual a
todo esto lo que voy a hacer es
simplemente copiar y pegar y copiar y
pegar y ahí está ok perfecto ahora que
puedo hacer está bastante interesante
esto no sé si tú veas aquí algo a verán
pone pausa el vídeo y intenta ver algo
ahí hay algo escondido que puedes ver si
simplificamos simplemente si restamos el
esto y esto de ambos lados de la
ecuación nos que nos queda ahí que nos
queda lo puedes ver porque ahí está eso
es el secreto de todo esto nos queda al
cuadrado más b al cuadrado es igual a se
al cuadrado y que es eso eso es el
famosísimo teorema de pitágoras ahí lo
tienen entonces al cuadrado más b al
cuadrado es igual a sea al cuadrado
genial genial ok ahí está gracias a
james garfield gracias a este caballero
de fina estampa gracias al veinteavo
presidente de eeuu hoy nos otro
podemos estar disfrutando de una de las
demostraciones del famosísimo teorema de
pitágoras